I'm a conservative Republican and I'm a
liberal Democrat we disagree on all
kinds of things but today we want to
focus on what unites us as Americans
like one of our founding documents the
Bill of Rights the First Amendment
freedom of speech wait does that include
what about hate speech like Fox News
dirty sanchez waffle arabian sandstorm
the Second Amendment the right to keep
and bear arms wait a second the third
Amendment protection from quartering of
troops
basically it means the government can't
turn your home into military housing I
got no beef with that me neither
the Fourth Amendment protection from
unreasonable search and seizure well I
say back the badge only criminals worry
about warrants
the men in it but what if we need
another sculpture garden the government
should be able to eminent domain
anybody's house this is the men a minute
speedy trials for everyone there's been
a war this one I just don't get you ever
actually read this thing I don't think
so
Bonanno where's the amendment that lets
the president run car companies have a
map of left and right maybe it's time to
get some reason